un golpe de timón de los líderes
europeos que han decidido ampliar las
sanciones contra el régimen de belarús
los jefes de estado y de gobierno
reunidos en bruselas han decidido cerrar
el espacio aéreo a las compañías aéreas
de vela rus tampoco se les permitirá
aterrizar en ningún aeropuerto de la
unión europea además se recomienda a
todas las compañías aéreas europeas que
no sobrevuelen el espacio aéreo de vela
rusa para evitar episodios como el del
pasado domingo estas acciones podrían
afectar gravemente a la economía del
país y además prácticamente a aislarla
además también han decidido aplicar
nuevas sanciones a altos cargos del
régimen de hecho hay casi ya 90 personas
sancionadas entre ellas el propio
presidente del país alexandr lukashenko
y también se ha acordado nuevas
sanciones económicas a sectores clave el
aterrizaje forzoso en el aeropuerto de
minsk de un vuelo en el que se
encontraba el opositor romano
protosevich y que fue arrestado al
llegar al país ha sacudido a las
capitales europeas
los jefes de estado y de gobierno han
asegurado que la situación es muy grave
que se puso en grave peligro a los
civiles y que era necesario actuar con
celeridad la presidenta de la comisión
europea úrsula von der leyen ha
prometido que si él lukashenko decide
devolver la democracia al país se
ayudará a belarrús con un paquete de
ayuda de tres mil millones de euros que
ahora mismo está congelada